الفرق بين العدوى المصحوبة بأعراض
كما نراه هنا
يبدو أه وليس أعراضًا
مدى أهميته جيدًا يخبرنا ببعض
الأشياء أولاً وقبل كل شيء
ما نعرفه هو أنه عندما يكون شخص ما على
الأرجح معديًا
من هذا ، فعادة ما يكون ذلك
مفاجئًا في  قبل يومين من
ظهور الأعراض عليهم ، فهذا شيء
ستركز عليه أدوات تتبع الاتصال التي كان يتحدث عنها جيم أكوستا للتو
،
إذا كانت هذه هي النقطة التي بدأت فيها
في تطوير الأعراض ، فمن المحتمل
أنك كنت تفعل معظم ما
يسمونه  تساقط فيروسي في الزوجين
قبل ثلاثة أيام من ذلك
جيدًا ، لذا تظهر أعراض يوم الجمعة يوم الخميس ،
لذا ستعود الآن إلى الثلاثاء أو
الاثنين
من حيث العدوى ، كما أنه
يحدث فرقًا
على الجانب الخلفي من حيث الوقت الذي
قد يتم تطهيره من الشخص.
عادةً ما يستغرق العزل 10 أيام على الأقل بعد
ظهور الأعراض الأولى ،
لذا فهذه هي الصلة الأخرى بها ومن
ثم تعرف أنك تريد فقط
معرفة محاولة  ct هل سيكون
هذا شيئًا سيسبب
مرضًا أكثر خطورة
أم لا تعلمون أنني سأريك شيئًا
سريعًا تعرفه من
الناحية الإحصائية بشكل عام ، فإن الاحتمالات في
جانب الرئيس
إذا نظرت حتى أنك تأخذ في
الاعتبار سنه وما قبله  -
الظروف الحالية
لا تزال على قيد الحياة بنسبة 90 95 في المائة مع
هذا ، لذلك
من المهم أن تأخذ كل ذلك
في سياقه
بالنظر إلى ما نعرفه عن هذا
الحمل الفيروسي الذي يعد عاملاً كبيرًا هنا من حيث
قابلية
الانتقال ، ومقدار الفيروس
المليء به نوعًا ما
هل تشير الأعراض إلى
وجود حمولة فيروسية ثقيلة ،
نعم هذا سؤال جيد ،
أعني أن هناك بعض الدراسات
التي ذكرت
مؤخرًا أن الأشخاص الذين يتعرضون
لحمل فيروسي أعلى هم أكثر عرضة للإصابة
بالأعراض وهناك بعض الأدلة على  أنك
تعرف أن الأمر كذلك إذا كنت غير
مقنع تمامًا وكان الناس من حولك
غير مقنع وكنت في مكان داخلي
به تهوية سيئة
، فمن المحتمل أن تكون الأحمال الفيروسية  أكبر
ولكن أعتقد أن
إحدى النقاط الأكثر أهمية
هنا وأعتقد أن هذا هو الاختلاف في
هذا الفيروس المعين
هو أن العدوى مثل مدى
عدوى شخص
ما تميل إلى أن تكون الأعلى في الزوجين
قبل ثلاثة أيام من ظهور الأعراض